problema número 205 de la siguiente
tabla cuál es el número de canicas
verdes en las jarras q y r tenemos esa
tabla en donde nos dicen la jarra p q r
el número de canicas de color rojo que
tiene cada una
aquí con variables el número de canicas
color verde que tiene cada una y el
total de canicas por have nos piden las
canicas verdes en las jarras q y es
bueno aquí tenemos que encontrar el
valor de z y bueno aquí tenemos tres
variables x y y ceta y tenemos tres
ecuaciones con una dos tres
esta es una ecuación es porque si yo en
esta línea sumo x más bien me va a dar
igual a 80 lo mismo aquí abajo y aquí
también en la tercera jara tratemos de
resolver estas ecuaciones restemos x
maceta
esta última ecuación le vamos a restar
la primera ecuación x más como la vamos
a restar le vamos a cambiar los signos
aquí en lugar de ser x positivos ser
menos x y aquí en lugar de sergio
positivo va a ser menos
en un 100 igual a 80 80 hacemos la resta
x x 0 aquí es z menos de aceta menos ye
igual a 160 menos 80 que aquiles me
falta poner el signo porque es menos
menos 80 va a ser igual a 80 positiva 80
muy bien ahora a este resultado vamos a
sumarle el de la jarra q de éste gemma z
voy a poner primero la zeta y luego
layer para que coincidan con estas
variantes es lo mismo tienen están
sumando estas dos no importa si yo
cambio el orden se está más igual a
ciento veinte 120 sumamos todo esto se
está maceta 2 z menos yemas lleva a ser
cero y esto va a ser igual a 80 120 va a
ser igual a 200 z es igual a 200
2 z es igual a 200 no hay que irse con
la finta vamos a dividir todo en todos
de manera que resista va a ser igual a
200 entre 2 va a ser igual a 100 y esta
es mi opción d
siguiente problema problema número 206
en el siguiente círculo el segmento pq
pq este de acá es paralelo al diámetro o
r que tiene una longitud de 18
anotemos la longitud que tiene aquí de
aquí acá son 18 todo esto
cuál es la longitud del arco de pq el
arco es esta parte curva esta fracción
de la circunferencia que estoy señalando
acá nos piden saber la longitud de este
arco
aquí podemos encontrar el total de esta
circunferencia bastante fácilmente ya
que spears por diámetros conozco el
diámetro y conozco la circunferencia es
igual a el diámetro que es 18 por pi y
para encontrar este arco deberemos
encontrar este ángulo que se forma que
de gm se lo señaló tengo que encontrar
un ángulo que va del centro del círculo
a este punto p y del centro del círculo
a este punto q si yo encuentro el ángulo
que está acá voy a poder proporcionar lo
a la longitud que se encuentra aquí en
la circunferencia entonces quiero
encontrar este ángulo de acá como lo voy
a hacer bueno veamos los datos nos dicen
que este ángulo de acá es de 35 grados
por la propiedad de que tengo dos líneas
paralelas y una transversal los ángulos
internos van a ser iguales quiere decir
que si este ángulo 75 grados este ángulo
de acá
también lo será ok ya llevo a un paso al
menos aquí un fragmento de agua que otra
cosa sé qué interesante aquí tenemos un
triángulo isósceles déjenme explicarles
por qué de aquí a que esto es un radio
que es la mitad del diámetro entonces la
mitad de 18 es 9 de aquí acá esto mide 9
de aquí acá también mide 9 estos dos
lados miden lo mismo entonces este
triángulo así como alargado que vemos
aquí es un triángulo isósceles el tengo
lo y sociales recordemos que tiene dos
lados iguales y los ángulos de esos
lados también van a ser iguales
permítanme dibujarlas este triángulo
aquí ahorita para que lo podamos
analizar mejor más o menos de aquí a acá
luego de aquí acá así que este tengo lo
está sobre uno de sus lados ha costado y
bueno quizás no está así exactamente las
medidas pero este lado mide 9 y este
lado también porque son los radios es un
radio cada lado así que estos dos lados
son iguales aquí nos están diciendo que
este ángulo es de 35 grados
el otro ángulo del lado que es igual a
este este ángulo de acá también va a
medir 35 grados y si vemos ese ángulo
pues que creen que corresponde a este
chiquito de acá sdk también es de 35
grados muy bien ya tenemos el ángulo de
uno de los vértices de este tema
ok 35 35 va a ser 70 este ángulo
completo de aquí acá va a ser igual a 70
grados pero que quede en este triángulo
con estos lados naranjas también es un
triángulo isósceles esto ya creemos que
este lado mide 9 y este también es un
radio de aquí acá también mide 9 estos
dos lados este y este miden lo mismo por
lo tanto estos dos ángulos que
corresponden a estos lados iguales
también van a ser iguales
así que si aquí tenemos 70 grados este
ángulo de acá también va a medir 70
grados muy bien ya tenemos dos ángulos
de ese triángulo y
vemos que la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo siempre nos va
a dar 180 grados
entonces sumamos estos ángulos 70 grados
más
este otro ángulo que también es de 70
grados este ángulo que es el que me
interesa y que le voy a poner aquí x más
x
esto debe ser igual a 180 grados igual a
180 70 más 70 es 140 más x escribo bien
es temas que no se notan mucho ahí está
más y si es igual a 180 si restamos 140
en ambos lados nos va a quedar que x es
igual a 180 menos 140 pues va a quedar
40 grados este ángulo de aquí es de 40
grados x igual a 40 y ahora sí con este
ángulo de acá podemos encontrar la
proporción de la circunferencia de este
arco así que tenemos que este ángulo de
40 grados su proporción con respecto a
todo
toda la circunferencia de los 360 grados
de un círculo 40 a 360 va a ser igual a
la longitud de este arco pq lo pongo acá
pq que todavía no conozco cuánto es
entre toda la circunferencia que
queremos que la circunferencia es igual
a 18 pi entre 18 mil y ahora tenemos que
despejar esta pq esta variable esto lo
puedo simplificar dividiendo el
numerador y el denominador entre 40 esto
me queda 1 y aquí me va a quedar 9 esto
es un noveno igual a pq entre 18 y
multiplicamos todo por 18 pi y nos va a
quedar 18 pi entre 9 es igual al arco pq
y 18 entre 9 es igual a 2 así que este
arco es igual a 2 pi que es nuestra
opción
y con esto terminamos los problemas de
este vídeo nos vemos en los siguiente